Now that we've used docker to
start multiple instances Of our
Inganest container.
I want to show you how to
communicate with them.
What we can do is look
at the container ID
of a docker instance
using the PS command.
I'll copy the container ID and
use a docker inspect command
to find out more information
about a specific container.
>From the output I can see the IP
address of the container.
I can then use curl to hit
the engine next instance
running inside of the container.
And there you go,
we're talking to that instance.
Now that we're done with our instances,
let's clean up.
When we want to stop these docker
instances, we'll use the docker stop
command with the container IDs of the
instances we want to remove, like this.
And we'll use the docker rm command
to remove our docking containers from
our system and
any file they may have left behind.
And we can verify the three inganest
instances are no longer running
using the docker ps command.
And we'll use the docker rm command to
remove our docker containers from our
system and any files that
they may have left behind.